oh [ __ ] I'm out in the slums again guys
god damn it at least I have my fidget
finger [ __ ] you buzzfeed [ __ ] you I quit
my job at BuzzFeed by the way did not
get fired
I quit me and Dave we're supposed to
quit together but that mother [ __ ]
placed it out on me
god dammit Dave well at least I have my
underwater rants
smiled anyway I'm gonna have to find a
new job guys luckily there's a wide
market out there I don't need you bust
feed they didn't even use my correct Pro
minute pronoun I'm as dragon skater 1969
X X X Y X X X you know what I bet they
fired me because I was white there's one
company I always wanted to work on
Nintendo let's see what it's like to
work at Nintendo everyone you work hard
I do good job I do nice to your
customers yes then must you suffer the
headache of returns [ __ ] returns I
swear to God if dave returns dr. Mario
again I thought it was the real Super
Mario and I got this Tetris piece of
[ __ ] game god damn it that actually
happened to me my dad bought me dr.
Mario but I didn't have the heart to
tell him that and he bought the wrong
Super Mario dad I'm sorry but you bought
dr. Mario you didn't buy Super Mario but
in a retrospect I actually enjoyed dr.
Mario a lot more even though I in the
beginning I pretended that I liked
playing dr. Mario just because there was
such a nice gift that you gave me even
though probably mom forced you to buy it
for me you'll need to go right back
there to the electronics area maybe
happy to have this just go to the back
he'll help you I'm A ha they make it
they openly admit that they're making it
as hard as possible to return your
[ __ ] game either I'm gonna do for you
customer service set me over to talk to
you to give this to you if you take a
look at the [ __ ] did he do without any a
Nintendo go through the apocalypse Jesus
Christ man to the matter that it was
working and now it's not working as so
I'd appreciate if you you know take a
look at it I'd like to get an exchange
for it if I can exchange yes sir well do
you have yes I better take a look yeah
that's right thank you do you know
what's on here No
I mean the kids couldn't have done
anything I mean they're good kids
sometimes they'll put soft drink or
something on their puts a soft drink in
there Nintendo you best be crazy dog no
no no it's not sort of pop I don't know
it's not soda pop I'm glad we got that
out of the way it's not soda pop guys it
was fun but just I'd appreciate if I had
an extra exchange on it that's come
there it's Carmona's Nintendo with what
kind of games did you play back there
are they playing Custer's revenge the
kids Jesus Christ and how about the
customer who tries to bully you into
taking back something you know isn't
broken these guys are a real problem
you people amaze me it really amazed me
your quality control people they just
have bats in the belfry about this game
boy yes Jay took it home nothing
absolutely nothing no picture I'm pretty
sure it's the EEPROM so if you just want
to take a look at that I'd fix it myself
but I don't really have the tools so
I'll take my money back sorry you had a
problem
got the music uh-huh
here we go I think this probably the
problem yeah just needed to turn up the
contrast a bit how's that look oh wow
that looks amazing
whoa he just needed to turn up the
contrast abate what a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you didn't know the old contrasts a bit
of course the contrasts I think that was
probably Mike Mike my kid didn't eh I'll
take it the controller doesn't work oh I
get there's a picture but there's no
action possibly I didn't read the
instructions right I take a look here
see how it works I didn't want to have
to bring it it but I just couldn't get
it to work
[Music]
did you try plugging it in you dumb
[ __ ] god damn I hate this day I hate
that I would hate this job thank you so
much oh thank you so much I didn't think
about plugging it in thank you tell me
when you plugged it in did you put it in
- hey telly why wouldn't you plugged it
in did you plug it up your ass is that
what you did because you're a [ __ ]
idiot port number one or port number two
oh my god
god bless they they didn't see anything
wrong with that question Nintendo so
tell you later where did you which port
did you put it in was it number one or
number two well plug it into number one
because if you put it into number two it
won't work you heard it here first folks
Nintendo said it themself if you put it
at number two it won't work god bless
you Nintendo you're a great great
family-friendly company I really
appreciate your family friendliness here
it makes me feel really good that you
you know maybe I can't walk out a
Nintendo after all they don't appreciate
number two a little disgusted by this in
many cases the customers simply failed
to follow the simple directions packaged
with their product most of the times
people are just [ __ ] idiots the
training kit is there to help you when
you have or a given some spare time
review it there's no telling what you
might pick up that will help you during
the next occasion you have to deal with
a customer return an INT a customer
return sounds too scared for me what
other jobs do we have now displays with
Jake
hi I'm Jay oh god Jake please there you
are sometimes you want to change the
volume on this as well that we have to
run around to the side here the side
panel will open up if you take the same
key and open the lock on the back of the
display open up that lock open the side
panel and if you look right down here
you'll see a little blue block with
little teeny tiny switches on it right
above that is little thing that looks
like a screw head okay take the
screwdriver you got in your kit yep and
turn that little screw head one way or
the other to adjust the volume that's
given just about like the volume up
really I how high do you like the volume
say that again please
really okay all right then good good to
know thank you be sure to put in your
screwdriver and you know me I like it up
real loud hi again again take that tube
and turn the volume up or down as you
see fit now you know me I like the
volume up really oh Jesus Christ he
scares the [ __ ] out of me I can't
imagine working with him I'll take any
other job
here we go soft drinks lemonade water
cold tea it's up to you it's up to me
cold drinks come in for cuts gonna know
the size before you fill it up biggie
medium small kids meal keep it straight
it's a good day use the scoop to fill
with ice never use the cup take my
advice but soft drinks throw the is half
way no matter the Sun that's what I say
[Music]
[Music]
you know on second thought maybe not
maybe not working whinnies man never not
God that was the worst [ __ ] [ __ ] I
don't want my customers to have problems
because I didn't do my job right
[Music]
thank you ma'am have a nice day and come
back Oh John I love to see customers
happy the program robots
don't say the same thing over and over
again like a broken record hi welcome to
Hardee's hi welcome to Hardee's hi
welcome to Hardee's hi welcome to
Hardee's hi welcome to heart rates high
hi welcome to high hi welcome hi welcome
to
my star service hello and welcome today
we'll explore the meaning of five-star
service and how we can provide it to
every guy I don't care we make eye
contact smile and offer a simple
greeting or a friendly wave Jesus Christ
working service in America must be a
[ __ ] nightmare Jesus Christ how do
you not kill yourself my god oh jesus
lord I must be so low soul-crushing to
have that job my god that's why they're
always so fake in America and I'm like
why is everyone so nice to me because
I'm Pony Power Hour that must be it
that's good chicken hey this is the hook
hell yeah that's a nice hook man oh okay
I will work at KFC everyone I'm so
excited to be working at KFC from now on
BAM I'm at KFC everyone fry in your
chicken wing if you ever meet me there
just be ask for the hook and I'll hook
you up buddy but remember you got to
smash that like button for a chance that
I can win an Amazon gift card so please
smash that like button and I'll see you
bros in the next video frying them
check-in way stay awesome bros hi
welcome to Hardee's hi welcome to
Hardee's hi welcome to Hardee's hi